you guys to it great great so it's been
like a year how was last year been it's
been crazy we prepared the world
premiere at TIFF where we saw you the
day we premiered the movie to the entire
world and we've been to 40 film
festivals all around the world almost on
every continent except for Antarctica
and now we're coming up to the
theatrical release of the movie Friday
the 13th so it's been a pretty check it
out it's been very crazy
first of all I'll say it again so people
can hear me but I mean I think you guys
did such a fantastic job with this and I
think what most impressed me is you made
the movie for a dollar fifty and a roll
of duct tape and so I am talk a little
bit about it's a big you have a big
movie here that you're trying to make
with you know very limited resources
absolutely well Zach and I were sort of
struggling filmmakers who were buddies
and saying oh my gosh like we got to
make a movie but none of these movies
are getting made that that that have
hired us sometimes we got fired so
what's the movie that we can make even
if we have a dollar fifty that can still
be in that kind of voice that we that we
want to express and one of the things we
we did was we created a story that had
really you know interesting characters
because we needed to attract actors and
that's one of the things you can do even
if you have no money just try to make
these characters twisted and interesting
and and and you know in this muddy gray
area of morality
so that actors who read it really want
to play those roles even if you only
have a dollar fifty actors get paid we
can't pay you a lot but this is it this
is a character you were born to play
right but one of the things I also think
that you did such a good job with is you
shoot it from Lexie's perspective the
the main star if you will in the film
talk a little bit about why you chose to
do that yeah we were really inspired by
a lot by Adams son as he's growing up
you know kids have a really unique
perspective on the world because they
don't know what's real and what isn't to
them a car alarm is incredibly scary but
dragons are real and totally cool and so
we wanted to tell a movie
from the perspective of a kid and we
took that to heart through the whole
movie she you know the genre of the
movie changes as her emotions change you
know looking up at these kind of
intimidating scary adults who are
looming over a lot of looking up adults
noses because the whole movie is
basically shot up from two feet off the
ground but that also leads into the way
the story structured because she's
trying to figure out what what's real
and what isn't and it's a sci-fi world
so the audience doesn't know what's real
and what isn't until Chloe knows
completely and that's another thing is
that I've seen the movie twice now the
second time you see it it's a completely
different movie you know and so talk a
little bit about like planting your
planting seeds through the whole movie -
at the bigger picture talk a little bit
about that so for people it's like a
rewatchable film yeah the really cool
thing about the film is as you're
watching it you have no idea at the
beginning what is going on and there's
all these confusing things happening but
they do all add up and so it's kind of a
mystery box as you're watching it the
first time and when you watch it the
second time it's really cool because all
these things that we're kind of
confusing and weird at the beginning now
completely make sense and you have this
really cool experience of kind of having
a second perspective on the film when
you watch it a second time it's really
fun what I was gonna say just jump on
something else when you so you're
getting ready to go film this you know
you have your limited schedule you you
know what I mean you're trying to do a
lot what's the thing that really made
you nervous before filming began in
terms of just how are we gonna get this
I think you know when you're working
with a kid you're extremely limited
because by law they can only work eight
hours a day so that was a big challenge
she's in every scene and she's driving
every scene forward so we had to be very
careful with kind of how we were using
her and what we were doing without her
and to make sure she has to be
emotionally ready to do the whole film
like it's not just a movie where she's
just sort of looking at all the adults
acting she is the lead of the movie
propelling everything forward and making
sure we had a seven-year-old girl who
could hold up an entire movie years and
years and years of all of our efforts
coming down to basically the shoulders
of this seven-year-old girl
and luckily through that process of
making the movie she's super stellar
when people come out of the film
she's usually the thing that everyone's
talking about oh no she did a fantastic
job when did you realize that she was
the one and when during the let me let
me stop there yeah I mean I for me the
moment I realized Lexi was the one is in
the very first audition she did we had
got her kind of connected to her
emotions she was screaming at this after
we had our nostrils were flaring her ear
her ears were tearing up her eyes were
tearing up and she was just totally in
the moment and we were all just kind of
leaning back in our chairs we said okay
good cut good good and then she just
immediately flipped and was like that
was so much fun you guys are great I
this is and we realized she had the
maturity to both go to these deep real
places but then also still be a little
girl and still have fun and not get lost
in some of that darkness and that was
really key because we're gonna be going
to a lot of crazy dark places over the
course of making this movie we needed
someone who who had the maturity to kind
of do that but also happen to be seven
years old Bliley I'm curious so you go
in the editing room you have all your
footage what's the thing when you start
looking at all the footage that you were
like most excited about and what was the
thing that terrified you Wow well I
think it's it's sort of the same answer
for both which is we used a lot of
improv in this movie to get at those
real emotions especially with Lexi but
also Bruce Dern is famous for improv he
just basically you know uses the script
as a jumping-off point to go to crazy
town which we encouraged because we
wanted to kind of find the realness in
there's relationships helpful when
you're the writer directors because you
can kind of use the script when you want
it but also throw it out and yeah so so
from an editing perspective we knew Lee
had lots of like rough gems in there
somewhere but we had to dig through to
find them and and you know chisel them
to make them work together you know the
visual effects were also a crazy thing
that we were sort of excited about but
intimidated by because we had a
dollar-fifty
and so we had to kind of be very crafty
with how we were doing the visual
effects and recruit a lot of friends to
do his favors basically we were back
you know anyone we knew who had visual
expect effects experience to help us out
yeah it's interesting when the movie
starts it seems like it's gonna be this
small little movie in a house and by the
end it becomes quite a large movie but
we needed it too we were a small movie
night so we needed to be able to pull
off all those visual effects there's you
know there's almost 250 shot visual
effects shots in the movie and but you
know we basically had to do it beg
borrow and steal it
Congrats cuz it works I wish you guys
nothing but the best and congrats on the
movie thank you you know where you are
our first interview Toronto and now you
know it's a year later yeah thank you